we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P
I don't really know what to make of this
call it's a caller who says he's obese
and he's he's called in before and I he
is obese I believe that part that's not
the joke but he says he identifies as
thin I don't know let's see what you
make of this I don't know if this is
like an anti-trans thing or what no joke
really no joke I am an obese male
but you know what I identify as a
sin
muscular man okay
why well
I'm obese compared to who compared to a
sumo wrestler I am pretty darn thin
so yes I identify as
a thin muscular man even though I am an
obese
person
with metabolic syndrome
why am I saying all of this yeah
what's the difference I really don't
understand the difference
between what
you don't understand the difference
between what and what
a between a trans person expressing
their gender
and an obese person saying they identify
as muscular and then I don't know but if
there's any greater confusion about
trans people than that voicemail I
certainly haven't seen it we've got a
great bonus show for you uh there is a
new poll
which we talked about at the top of the
show from ABC and we talked about the
top level results but there are some
other results that are interesting
including one that shows that under 35
of the population right now believes Joe
Biden has the mental sharpness required
for a second presidential term we will
discuss that will that become a problem
the Seattle Public Library system has
launched a program to allow teens to
access books that have been banned we
will discuss that and lastly in the wake
of this horrifying horrifying shooting
in Texas a Texas lawmaker is lobbying to
teach third graders to do first aid for
gunshot wounds so that if there's a
shooting in one of their classmates gets
shot the third graders who would be
between eight and nine years old would
be prepared to administer gunshot
related first aid this is where we are
in Texas in the United States all of
those stories and more when I am joined
by producer pat on the bonus show oh the
bonus show where you you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad super strong
bonus show today I do think today will
make money on the bonus show last week
we took out a day off for making money
on the bonus show but this week we
should do it uh also I have just been
notified that Steve Bannon is now coming
after me so we're going to review that
I'll probably have more for about that
for you either on the bonus show or
tomorrow join pacman.com is the place to
sign up we will see you then